to me we're fading every hair matters so
I'd like to get up one and feed my
eyeball
so I look I'm gonna be working on a
funky original part from the 80s making
the comeback in a futuristic way today's
topic is Diane Williamson the NBA's
rocking star
come on in DeAndre hey my brother how
are you man man you got the perfect
perfect campus what I'm gonna do what
I'm really cool that affiliate fee
that's part of Zion we have this haircut
look please decide right here real nice
and tight let's swing around and put
that iconic Z on the left side of your
head so DeAndre let's look at some cool
pictures of Zions here so this is when
design was I guess first growing out his
height something like this cut right
here is really taking shape the feed
with the monkey from barbers in some
cases is high and his right side in some
cases it's lower on his right side
so what we're looking at here is his
season debut the new fee CR the fade is
right here let's go back to his doop
days look at the fade here see how much
lower the faith is yeah like it's paid
back in his new days rather than how it
is now more definition so I hook you up
with a little feed from the other side
we're gonna get that Z just like here on
this photo I'm down with that
its iconic it's fresh he started off
with the thing right
get my mastana aasman caliber to put in
the guideline so here right here I'd
like to start over alone and the bowling
right here you're gonna move it in an
angle as you can see these dry canvases
are best so while I'm in the fade motion
I'm gonna go ahead and kill sit on and
just shade space I put my first
guideline in so now we're ready to go to
the adjustable Club so I got my 50 bags
count I want to start to take some of
the weight line out and the boss out
down to the taper so I can feed a nice
and easy side profiles agree to start
off this is a 1.5 guard oh very powerful
so want to take my first wipe here to
get a feel always remember God's easy
just touch service here is very good for
this cut but how often do you recommend
to wash your hair because under her
you're not supposed to wash it every day
that right there that's a problem when
people say that you don't not supposed
to wash your hair every day you can wash
your hair every day because it's a part
of your body is a part of your hygiene
there's nothing wrong with Washington
okay whatever you take out of your hair
oils and put the same examples back in
your hair there's nothing wrong with
washing your hair no yeah the hot top
the long long time ago and I asked for
college high school didn't go to college
they even high school middle school
so that was like in the 80s you know
1988 to 1992 like a baggy pants right
yeah the baggy pants were in back that's
funny how things come back around I call
it the remix like puffy said he invented
the remix the remix so while I'm going
this and just working on taking out the
late line here right directly right in
this section put on the low and angle
right here Brady go for the finishing
touches with the fade or come back to
the guard actually but I need to take it
off right now so we're gonna clean it
off so I'm going to my next step so
tapering blending your big guideline and
shoe with the ball feet and just you
don't have to go all the way up you can
kind of like use the comb as a guard to
stop that you keep that clean trees now
this is important to start peaking at so
you don't breathe it to make another
line the biggest mistake that you can
make with fading is taking a fade too
high because you need canvas I'll call
this construction paper to work so while
my guard is off you know you do most of
my paintings out of guard and keep calm
with him what wait lines are is when the
hair is thick in the face then I
wouldn't know these 50 bags looks so
quietly
so whereas I'm working over on the right
side here you know what a clean is go to
yup I finished my fade meal we're gonna
clean it up clean it up some more at the
end but this is what that low skin feed
looks like here a favorite type of hair
you like to cut like waves are like a
favorite style they make her one of my
favorite styles is to fake up because I
like to show my work I like to break it
down into the vision steps and phase you
go from a zero to a one the one that
flows to to a peaceful for to a five I
want people when it comes from me
cutting hair I want people to see the
behind
like that that's a tight fee who cuts
your hair this gentleman here is like a
walking billboard for me I'll put the
city man back so now I'm going back to
my non non serious mallanna here cut
like this $30 I used to be five so I'll
just put a little light light on the
front of it here so that thing is done
which I think it's clean right so the
next step I think I want to go to the Z
on your left side and left and left a so
hit it left here so yeah this is what
everybody wants to see it the Z what I
have here and I'm going to do go back to
my 50 bags so I'm gonna swipe down take
uh some of the bulk off to make it easy
for the outliner
very important to keep the area clean
and making the putts with a cold
favorite TV show blowing up in the 90 my
favorite TV show blood up at the
eighties in the nineties with the 18
1918 was that you don't know about the
18 mr. t oh yeah yeah no that is mr. t
ba Baracus was iconic as well with this
haircut
he had the whole oh yeah and he's like
one of my favorite individuals of all
time he had the gold chains and he knew
how to fix cars and make bombs and guns
and vehicles like that was my childhood
idol mr. t so you know when doing these
type of parts nowadays you know you'd
like to grab your razor to cleanly like
the access here I'll be inside brother
razor this was my favorite because it
has a pull handle so I like to you know
get up in the park with the razor just
clean that excess here you have to be
very very careful in this because you
can cut something so you just kind of
like tracing the line that the outliner
made so you could just clean it up one
of the rules involved when using razor
work please do not move because you can
cut somebody if you really want to get
down to it to make that perfect Z you
can fill it in with hair fibers you saw
me doing the James Harden and I'm going
to just put the card right here one of
the hair fibers made of crushed up
synthetic hair they just sprays out like
a Miss you know own to the hair and as a
barber do you frown upon like people
using rulers and like puppets
shape-ups I really do I think it's like
a it's a craft it should be because it
is a bargain is a built-in crap
it's art so using rulers in you know
handheld tools to help affect the cut is
like forbidden for me I would never do
that so how do you feel so good I want
to know what to do invite you are you
excited yes I can't wait to show you cuz
I want Zion to be happy when he sees
this to be like I'm really really
trending so I think I'm just about ready
to reveal the Z let me turn it around
well next up I got me a favor curly
bracket and see about to just cut a
little bit to make it you know pop by
Zion stop I need a little holding spray
I always go to the same direction when
I'm trying to make curls the twist here
hopefully in Lock individual so if you
go the opposite direction and like undo
the twists so I like to go into a
circular motion to walk it look like
little spiders up there just a favorite
part it's my favorite part
creating you know doing a feed which is
no feeding giving you it a little bit
you know does evil design I like that
you know I call it was looking forward
to do this haircut this is something
that this gentleman could do every
single day when you know he's homies you
know it's personal space you do the same
thing you don't want to do it in the
Train cuz you can drop it into
somebody's food with this particular
style you could do it degree to dry air
so you ready
let's get it let's get it hey yo
oh my god gum in the leg Zion wanting
some himself
[Music]
oh my god somebody that is nice that is
really nice oh that is really nice
attached to my one young man's on me I
appreciate you anytime and I want that
same discount okay you get it so we just
wrecked them an exciting episode that
make me look like you did a little cool
little fade a fraud on as I apart and a
curly top
keep those cool little comments coming
don't forget to smash a scrap button you
can also follow me on instagram at
father barber 1 until next time feel
good look good be good
[Music]
there's gonna be real witch
[Music]
[Applause]